- [Instructor] Many parts of
the United States Constitution deal
with rights of an individual,
and many amendments talk about protecting
or expanding the rights of an individual,
but the 14th Amendment is perhaps one
of the most important
amendments in this discussion
of protecting civil rights.
And, in particular, Section 1 is the part
that is most cited.
So, let's just read this together.
"All persons born or naturalized
in the United States,
"and subject to the jurisdiction thereof,
"are citizens of the United States
"and of the state wherein they reside.
"No state shall make or enforce any law
"which shall abridge the privileges
"or immunities of citizens
of the United States,
"nor shall any state
deprive any person of life,
"liberty, or property,
without due process of law,
"nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction
"the equal protection of the laws."
So, let's just focus in on parts of it.
So, one big takeaway
about the 14th Amendment,
this is the federal government saying,
"Hey, these are things
that the state cannot do."
So, for example, when it says,
"Nor shall any state
deprive any person of life,
"liberty, or property,
without due process of law,"
this is a restatement
of the 5th Amendment,
that, "Hey, you know,
people can't just stick you
"in jail or take away your
property without you going
"through some type of a
process, a legal process."
Well, in the 5th Amendment,
this was really talking about
the federal government not being able
to just take your property
or your liberty away
from you without the process of law,
but here, it's saying,
"Nor shall any state."
And this clause right over here,
this is known as the due process clause
of the 14th Amendment.
Then, right after that, it says,
"Nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction
"the equal protection of the laws.
"The equal protection of the laws,"
I'm gonna underline that.
And this, you might guess is called
the equal protection clause.
Now, the context in which the
14th Amendment was ratified,
it happens in 1868,
shortly after the end of the Civil War.
You, of course, have
the 13th Amendment that,
among other things, abolishes slavery,
but then, you have these things
in the south called black codes,
which continue to repress the
rights of African-Americans,
and that's why Congress felt the need
for the 14th Amendment to be passed.
Now, one of the most notable cases
in which the 14th Amendment
was brought up happens in 1896,
Plessy v. Ferguson,
and we have a whole video about this.
And this is a case in which it was argued
that is was unconstitutional
under the 14th Amendment
for African-Americans to have to travel
in a separate train car
from white Americans,
and the Supreme Court
infamously said that,
"Hey, as long as it is equal,
"it is okay for it to be separate
"and that it would not
violate the 14th Amendment,"
and so, this idea of separate
but equal comes about.
Now, that was significantly challenged
as we go into 1954,
where you have Brown v. Board of Education
of Topeka, Kansas.
Board of Education.
And here, the argument
was that, inherently,
separate could not be equal,
and once again, the 14th
Amendment was invoked.
And this time, the Supreme
Court unanimously ruled that,
yes, separate can't be equal,
and that the schools
needed to be desegregated.
So, even though it wasn't
an official overruling
of Plessy v. Ferguson, it
was a functional overruling
of this doctrine of separate but equal.
And, as we go into the
1960s civil rights movement,
led by folks like Martin Luther King,
it was the 14th Amendment
that was cited often.
In another video, we're going to look
at Martin Luther King's
letter from a Birmingham jail,
in which he articulates the ideas
of the civil rights movement,
it's a quite moving letter.
But, once again, it's evoking these ideas
of the 14th Amendment,
and it goes onto movements
as disparate as the
women's rights movement,
led by organizations like
the National Organization for Women,
citing equal protection of the laws
in situations of sexual
discrimination in the workplace.
You have pro-life groups
citing the 14th Amendment,
arguing that an unborn
fetus' right to life
is protected by the 14th Amendment.
You have rulings around whether quotas
in higher education are legal or not,
once again, citing ideas of
equal protection of the laws.
So, as you go forth in your study
of United States government,
the 14th Amendment,
especially Section 1, is
going to keep showing up.